tomás está estudiando para sus exámenes
finales esta semana y va a pasar un
quinto un quinto de su semana estudiando
qué fracción de su semana pasará
estudiando para cada una de sus cuatro
materias si decide que va a estudiar la
misma cantidad de tiempo en cada una de
ellas es decir que tomás durante todas
estas semanas va a pasar un quinto de su
semana estudiando vamos a ponerlo un
quinto de la semana lo va a pasar
estudiando ok pero todo este tiempo que
va a pasar estudiando lo va a dividir en
partes iguales entre sus cuatro materias
es decir a esto lo tenemos que dividir
lo tenemos que dividir entre sus cuatro
materias que van a ser su objeto de
estudio entre cuatro y bueno si te das
cuenta lo que estamos haciendo es
dividir lo que va a pasar el estudiando
entre la cantidad de materias que tiene
que estudiar pero como nosotros hemos
visto cuando tenemos una fracción
dividida
entre otra fracción o entre un número
para responder esto nos tomamos la
multiplicación por el recíproco de este
número pero cuál es el recíproco de 4
bueno es que al 4 lo podemos ver como 4
entre 1 y de esta manera ya podemos
encontrar de una manera sencilla su
recíproco esto es exactamente igual esto
es exactamente igual que tomarme un
quinto y déjame cambiar de color que
tomarme un quinto ya esto multiplicarlo
multiplicarlo por el recíproco de 4
entre 1 lo cual por cierto es lo mismo
que 1 entre 4 recuerda que el
denominador se pasa el numerador y el
numerador al denominador y esto es
exactamente lo mismo por todo lo que
hemos visto que uno por uno lo cual me
va a dar 15 por 4 lo cual es 20 es decir
que la fracción que va a pasar
estudiando por cada una de sus materias
es 1 entre 20 y como podemos ver esto de
una manera visual pues qué te parece si
traemos aquí esta caja que dice
y se nos va a servir bastante porque
esta caja lo que nos está diciendo es
que tenemos toda la semana de tomás
dividida en cinco partes iguales y de
estas partes solamente una quinta parte
solamente el primer rectángulo listo de
todos estos cinco lava para salto más
estudiando esto es lo que va a estudiar
temas de toda su semana ahora lo que
queremos es dividir todo esto entre
cuatro es decir entre cuatro materias
que él va a estudiar entonces vamos a
dividir toda esta caja entre cuatro voy
a dividir esta caja entre cuatro así que
por aquí me va a quedar la mitad ok
más o menos así y después por aquí me
van a quedar cuartos voy a dividir esto
a la mitad otra vez ok
algo más o menos así y por aquí también
voy a dividir a la mitad voy a dividir a
la mitad algo más
así de tal manera que aquí me quedan 20
cuadritos la semana ahora está dividida
en 20 cuadritos y de esos 20 cuadritos
nosotros nos vamos a tomar 4 para
estudiar ahora de estos 4 que tenemos
aquí que los vamos a ocupar para
estudiar date cuenta que solamente el
primero solamente el primero de ellos lo
vamos a utilizar para estudiar una de
las materias que es justo este 1 entre
20 que yo tengo aquí 1 entre 20 porque
solamente uno de todos estos 20
cuadritos que tengo aquí lo voy a ocupar
en estudiar una de las materias y ya
está si yo quiero dividir un quinto
entre cuatro es lo mismo que uno entre
20 que es justo me respuesta qué
fracción de la semana pasará estudiando
para cada una de sus materias
bueno pues va a pasar 1 entre 20 o un
veinteavo estudiando para cada una de
sus materias